les attentats de charlie hebdo ça a été
extrêmement difficile à vivre
pas que pour moi surtout pour l'équipe
de cash investigations parce qu'en fait
il se trouve que charlie venait
d'aménager quelques mois plus tôt dans
les mêmes locaux que nous au même étage
en fait ce jour là notre chargé de
production
c'était un mercredi et notre chargé de
production qui avait été embauché le
lundi mathieu est descendu fumer une
cigarette en fait il a vu les frères
kwasi au travers d'une vitre qui étaient
en plastique sable et enfin il voit deux
hommes en noir et il voit très
clairement qu'ils sont armés et ils
remontent comme une bombe
en dix ans il ya deux mecs armés en bas
âge pas ce qui se passe et edward perrin
immédiatement dit ça c'est pour charlie
donc il évacue tout le monde ils font
monter les gens de première ligne sur le
toit ils planquent toute l'équipe de la
rédaction et edward perrin et benoît
bringer deux journalistes de la
rédaction mais les gilets pare-balles et
se disent on va aller prévenir charlie
sauf qu'au moment où heath ils sortent
les frères kwasi arrive dans le couloir
nous on avait un oeilleton pour qu'ils
les voient après ils se déplacent pas
qu'il ya une deuxième porte ils essaient
de voir s'ils peuvent sortir par la
deuxième porte mais en fait c'était
comme un cul de sac donc il était
complètement enfin jarry se serait fait
tuer je pense très franchement et donc
ils sont démunis ils entendent les
frères kwasi qui rentre dans la
rédaction de charlie
ils entendent bien sûr la fusillade moi
je suis pas là ce moment là je suis en
train de préparer le 13 heures
je suis à la rédaction et puis il ya une
petite dépêche qui tombe dit fusillade
dans le 11e des blessés pas charlie
hebdo pas enfin rien de précis et moi je
m'inquiète pas enfin je me dis bon ou
c'est bizarre c'est quoi ce truc mais
pas plus que ça a très franchement
et puis un moment mon rédacteur en chef
du trésor philippe denis me dit c'est
bizarre il ya benoît bringer qui est en
train de parler sur bfm il y aurait eu
une fusillade à charlie hebdo et là ça
se connectent je comprend immédiatement
et je fais un truc que je vais le pense
je vais toujours regretter c'est que
j'ai appelé benoît et je fais un peu ma
chef quoi je lui dis bon benoît prenez
des caméras à les filmer journal de 13
heures c'est dans une heure et quart
faut qu'on ait des trucs
est ce que tu peux filmer du toit et
puis et puis je suis pas super parce que
je
business à peine le temps de réponse ils
me répondent pas aussi parce que je
pense qu'il est complètement sous le
choc
et au bout d'un moment il me répond il
me dit mme ellis n'a pas compris c'est
un massacre
c'est un massacre et là j'ai plus rien
dit et j'ai messi s'est passé et il m'a
dit sont rentrés ils ont ils ont rafalé
partout il ya des morts partout nous
nous ils sont pas rentrés chez nous il
n'y a pas de morts ya pas de blessé mais
c'est affreux c'est horrible on n'ose
pas sortir parce qu'il vient à peine
venait de sortir en fait ils espèrent
kwasi c'est les types de cages qui les a
filmés dans la rue il venait de tourner
le coin de la rue quoi et il va falloir
qu'on sorte parce qu'il faut qu'on aille
voir ce qui se passe en face et voilà ça
a été un truc affreux parce que moi je
me dis bon il faut que je présente le
journal
bonjour à tous émission spéciale de la
rédaction en raison de cette attaque
terroriste contre nos confrères de
charlie hebdo on arrive au bout du
journal on a dû faire une heure de
journal est là en fait la liste des
morts tombent pendant génériques et
c'est nathalie saint cricq qui me dit ah
et cabu est mort ce qui est mort bernard
maïs est mort et je pense que sur les
images on nous voit toutes les deux la
tête dans les mains comme ça en train de
se dire mais c'est pas possible
voilà et la suite a été extrêmement
difficile à vivre pour l'équipe de cash
parce que les premiers en fait à être
entré dans la rédaction de charlie c'est
des gens de chez nous c'était urgent de
cash
envoyé spécial s'est procuré des
documents inédits
une vidéo de la femme du candidat où
elle affirme qu'elle n'a jamais été
l'assistante de son mari l'interview de
pénélope fillon ça a été vraiment
quelque chose de très important dans
l'histoire de d'envoyé spécial
il y avait notamment je me souvient yvan
martin et tristan ou alex qui
travaillait là dessus à un moment il
vend martin et dia j'ai retrouvé une
journaliste anglaise qui s'appelle kim
wilshere qui a fait une interview de
pénélope fillon il ya deux ou trois ans
chez parce qu'elle dit dans mais bon ça
vaut peut-être le coup d'essayer de
rapatrier les rushes kimouche heures
diaba je les ai pas les rushs en fait
c'est mon caméraman de l'époque et les a
on prend contact avec lui on discute le
type nous dira je sais pas si j'ai
encore la cassette
oui en fait finalement il la retrouve
donc et puis on finit par signer un
accord avec lui nous envoie la cassette
et franchement on psa aurait rien du
tout enfin c'était vraiment deux
confrères un confrère
et voilà on obtient tous les rushes nos
journalistes sont en train de bosser
donc c'est un troisième journaliste
pierre maudet gier qui par le soir avec
les rushs qui en fait était sur un
fichier vidéo et donc il doit les
interviews est assez longue et donc il
doit écouter absolument tout le tous les
rushs de de pénélope fillon
et puis on a down the same groupe et on
est tous sur un whatsapp envoyé spécial
et là je pense qu'il était un truc comme
22h20 ou un truc comme ça et il nous
écrit à une heure 16 minutes et 12
secondes
elle déclare je n'ai jamais été
l'assistante de mon mari ou quoique ce
soit d'autre
et là on lit tous le what's app est un
fait ok pénélope fillon dit elle même
qu'elle a été rémunéré par fall dit pas
qu'elle a été rémunéré mais elle dit
qu'elle n'a jamais travaillé avec son
mari et on sait qu'elle a été régulière
ont réussi à garder ça secret pour nous
quarante-huit heures à peu près
et puis on est en montage ça commence a
fuité et ça monte ça monte ça monte ça
monte et on diffuse sa en exclusif dans
envoyé spécial
et ce jour là enfin il ya une audience
de dingue pour envoyé spécial mais pour
cause tout le monde voulait voir cette
vidéo de pénélope fillon qui disait
elle-même je n'ai jamais été assistante
de mon mari ou quoique ce soit d'autre
chapeau le boulot d'équipé parce qu'à un
moment c'est ça et j'ai je crois que
cette toute petite phrase qui doit faire
sept secondes à peine
elle pèse lourd aujourd'hui on rapporte
une histoire abracadabrantesque
on a un producteur extérieur qui
arrivent dans leur bureau et qui nous
propose juste avant le lancement
d'émissions la cassette méry la fameuse
cassette méry où jean claude méry parle
du financement occulte du rpr et en gros
accuse chirac d'avoir lui-même touché
des valises de billets et puis le parti
aussi pour son financement occulte sauf
que jean claude méry en question il est
mort donc on a la vidéo dans monsieur
dans un canapé avec des grosses lunettes
qui raconte ça et on se dit waow qu'est
ce que c'est que ce truc on présente la
cassette c'est à dire qu'on dit à arnaud
hamelin ok on prend parce que c'est un
document peut-être une énorme révélation
mais il faut qu'on travaille dessus il
faut qu'on fasse un travail
d'investigation dessus et c'était pour
le tout premier numéro de pièces à
conviction
et là on se dit bon on se donne deux
mois trois mois pour travailler et pour
faire un vrai travail d'investigation
dessus mais on n'a pas eu le temps
parce que moi en fait dix jours après
claude chirac m'appelle et elle me dit
on me la passe au téléphone je sens déjà
au courant qu'on a acheté la cassette
méry
pas du tout elle me dit oui vous
comprenez élisent le président souhaite
intervenir
et on est en septembre 2000 c'est juste
avant le référendum sur le quinquennat
et le président souhaitent intervenir
pour promouvoir le quinquennat expliquer
pourquoi c'est important de passer du
septennat au quinquennat j'ai bon
pourquoi pas effectivement intervenir
dans 19 heures dans le journal pour ça
on part à angoulême préfecture
d'angoulême c'est là qu'on a rendez vous
pour l'interview de jacques chirac et
d'entrain notre téléphone se met à
sonner on avait chacun deux portables ou
trois potable et ça se met à sonner de
partout et indiqué ce qui se passait en
trois minutes tournent à la réponse en
fait
arnaud hamelin était allé vendre la
cassette méry au monde au journal le
monde qui sachant qu'on avait chirac
décide de sortir l'intégralité de la
cassette méry dans l'édition de 14
heures et nous on faisait l'interview à
19h30 donc un truc de fou et on se
regarde avec hervé eon dit bon ben là
toute façon il faut absolument qu'on
parle de ce sujet avec le président de
la république et on se fait une promesse
sur le quai de la gare
on se dit si on ne peut pas le faire si
d'une manière ou d'une autre à cause de
l'elysée ou à cause de france
télévisions ne peut pas le faire on
démissionnera et on n'a pas démissionné
bon ça a été très long tout l'après-midi
moi j'avais claude chirac au téléphone
toutes les heures qui est énorme et pas
question il faut pas qu'on en parle qui
au bout d'une heure dit ok on en parle
au bout de deux heures me dit ok on en
parle d'accord en début d'interview
parce qu'elle voulait au départ qu'on en
parle en fin d'interview au haras vers
15 16 heures jeudi il ya des extraits de
la cassette méry sur le site du monde
début du site internet du monde ils
diffusent des caisses des extraits de la
cassette méry
j'ai donc on va diffuser aussi des
extraits de la cassette mais parce que
c'est public
là j'ai cru qu elle allait mes tripes et
au téléphone comme quoi vous allez
diffusé un extrait de cette cassette
j'ai ma femme c'est du domaine public
maintenant il
il faut qu'on diffuse des extraits la
casse est donc j obtiens que on n'en
diffuse et puis au final leur avance moi
j'ai à peine le temps de préparer mon
interview c'était vraiment extrêmement
tendue et à 18 heures elle m'appelle et
elle me dit elise le président de la
république souhaite vous parler en seul
à seul entre le journal régional et le
journal national ça on se dit que ça va
être un moment un peu tendu entre le
journal régional est journal national ya
sept minutes de pub de d'un terreau
programme et il s'avance vers moi il y
avait du mal à bruxelles vous n'êtes pas
sans ignorer que le journal le monde a
publié va évidemment monsieur le
président je suis au courant
il faut absolument qu'on en parle c'est
important pour l'interview il dit alors
écoutez alain musset voilà ce que je
vais vous dire il me sort la réponse à
la question des délais prévus et il me
dit abracadabrantesque dedans évidemment
et moi intérieurement je me dis mais la
france est riche femme qu'est ce que
c'est que ce mot bizarre et en fait j'ai
pas le temps de réfléchir à cela parce
que il finit ce moment entre nous en
disant vous comprendrez bien mal à mu
c'est que dans ces circonstances je ne
souhaite aucune relance et là je vois
leurs tournées ces antennes dans le
quatre minutes et je m'entends lui dire
écoutez monsieur le président cela ne va
pas être possible
et comme c'était jacques chirac
ça s'est plutôt bien passé c'est à dire
qu'il me dit mais pourquoi mal à
bruxelles je l'écouté monsieur monsieur
le président la france entière ne parle
que de ça depuis 14h c'est sorti dans le
monde c'est sur france info c'est
partout on ne parle que de ça personne
ne comprendrait que à l'issue de votre
réponse je ne vous pose aucune question
moi j'ai mon rôle de journaliste vous
vous avez votre rôle de chef d'état mais
c'est impossible que je ne vous pose pas
de question à dessus et là que chirac
antennes dans 20 minutes
donc ça commence à se crisper
sérieusement et jacques chirac m'a fait
une réponse incroyable et il me dit
écoutez bien amusé vous allez me poser
des questions et je ne vais pas y
répondre
antenne dans une minute et on rentre je
mets mon oreillette on s'installe et en
gros c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire que moi je leur lance une fois deux
fois trois fois derrière mais ils
meurent fait tout le temps la même
réponse il a décidé de ne pas me
répondre plus que ça et il change
évidemment un peu sa version mais il va
pas au delà
et ça a été quand même une sacrée
bataille pour arriver à ce moment là et
on est sortis en fait avec hervé brusini
mon directeur de l'info de france 3 à
l'époque assez élégamment c'est à dire
que jacques chirac nous un seul à lui
claude chirac noz à saluer on ya pas eu
une violence qui aurait pu avoir avec
d'autres chefs d'état que j'ai connu
dans d'autres moments